six one seven eight three zero forty
seven fifty let's jump over to our
caller from the 708 area code who's
calling today from 708 708 maybe we're
muted I don't know yo oh sorry hi who's
on yeah my name is all day I'm from
Chicago what's going on well I wanted to
ask so you've seen the Joe Rogan podcast
with Bernie Sanders I saw five minutes
of it honestly I don't know what else
happened I saw that you know it had
thousands of down votes not surprisingly
based on Joe's audience and I saw that
he was on about the first five minutes
why did did anything interesting go on
oh no no they just they just discussed a
lot of arms I mean it was it was really
well it was really well discussed you
guys are probably watch it yeah I was
gonna I was gonna ask do you think other
candidates should show up under the show
Rogan experience it's up to them I mean
I think so Andrew yang did it Tulsi
Gabbard did it I don't know who else has
been on with him but I mean it's a huge
platform it's one of the biggest
podcasts around I don't think I mean I
don't believe any publicity is good
publicity but certainly the Joe Rogan
experience is good publicity no matter
what your political orientation is I
feel like I'm just just from a I mean
listen there's even if his audience is
like a center-right audience in total
like a lot of people didn't like the
stuff I said on there but it still was
hugely beneficial for me so like yeah I
think why wouldn't I I can't think of
any reason why candidates would avoid it
mm-hmm interesting can you I mean what
is there do you think candidates should
stay away from his show no no no I think
um I think he is interested I think he
asks great questions and since our on
the podcast they can talk as long as
they want versus a debate which is like
15 seconds of response time so right I
think it's very nice okay in your
question you sounded a little bit like
hesitant like do what you know that
maybe people think they shouldn't be on
or something
hmm no I only sounded hesitant because
you you didn't watch the entire Bernie
the entire Bernie podcast so that's why
I was like that's why I says it's on to
question oh look at that point but never
mind them man no no general
I don't have to watch that specific
episode to say huge platform right
long-form which is great compared to the
debates as you're pointing out so yeah
why I think candidates should do it
thank you all right thank you for the
call appreciate all day from Chicago
great to hear from you